irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
oh
voici un monde de géants voici les andes
l'homme si leur table il fallut un géant
lui-même pour le vaincre tel mermoz
tombé sur une de ses pentes dénudées il
fallait repartir ou rire alors il lance
en appareils sur la pente miracles
il repart les deux géants étaient
quittes et la route des indes et est
ouverte
et pourtant ce n'était guère facile de
sur paul et s'étendent partout des
entonnoirs des trous d'air des
labyrinthes des ravines des vallées sans
eau et sans maison et pourtant chaque
mot est sillonnée d'un minuscule
sentiers alors cette vie que l'on ne
perçoit pas existe vous qu'elle allait
en amérique du sud vous savez au moment
où l'on se croit absolument seule passe
un homme qui il est et où va-t-il d'où
vient-il qu'elle aulas bref quelle
nourriture le rassasier personne ne le
sait cependant il est là lima elle
recèle l'une des plus belles histoires
d'amour celle de la périchole et du vie
soit il reste de tout ceci des palais
des arcades des balcons suspendus
et il reste aussi ce carrosse qui
confirme la légende ce carrosse du saint
sacrement qui devait conduire la
périchole à la célébrité
voici sa baignoire car elle aimait à
prendre son bain sous les hibiscus
balcons de bois
mieux vaut tél
archevêché
cathédrale tous témoins de lingerie qui
devait un jour de fête religieuse est
bouleversée et scandalisé lima
changeons de monde essayons de le mieux
connaître nous nous envolons vers cusco
capitale de la civilisation inca ousco
sac shawa man machu picchu citadelle où
on si j'ai les fils du soleil qu une
daube religieux trésor des incas source
d'or fabuleuse cité construite à 3400
mètres d'altitude un monde
oh
là bas au fond de la vallée
voici le couche co qui vient tanay
oh
on reçoit couscous comme un souffle
violent en plein visage
la rue attire les alliances y tiennent
les indiens non plutôt misé 1 k finie la
splendeur de cet empire cette ville
depuis des siècles se fraie un chemin
parmi les difficultés de toutes sortes
le
non
les témoignages qui ont été laissées par
ces surhommes nous passer c'est le
confondre une compréhension à travers
les âges les tremblements de terre les
rages espagnols les murs un quart
résiste et garde encore en eux le secret
de leur construction
bravo
voilà
où ce coût est située dans une vallée
fertile et à cette attitude pousse
encore toutes les céréales les incas on
connaissait plus de quinze espèces
différentes
la pomme de terre elle est originaire du
pérou etc de laquelle nous fut importée
au 16e siècle
l'art de la céramique semble être parmi
les premiers des populations près un
cacique les couleurs en sont le blanc le
rouge et le noir d'une pâte previn elles
représentent des personnages des animaux
le seul animal connu la paille et le
lama les autres furent importés par les
européens
administré par des princes âge chaque
enfant qui venait au monde recevait une
terre qu'ils avaient à charge de faire
produire pour la communauté
lorsque les conquérants voulurent
s'imposer il dure forte affaire il y eu
des massacres des répressions des ruines
dont les bases résistèrent à la
destruction parce que trop puissante
ils on construisit à nouveau cusco
les conquérants apporte architecture
religion peinture l'influencé indienne
apporte la naïveté qui fait retrouver
une fraîcheur primitive
c'est sur cette place devant une
cathédrale que les chefs et les grands
dignitaires se rassembler et prenez les
décisions importantes concernant
l'avenir de l'en pillent
ou ce qu est prouvé par un terrible
tremblement de terre se relève mal de
sirna
e
waouh
il sait maintenant avec de la boue de la
paille que l'on construit une maison et
les écoles pour une marmaille toujours
plus nombreuses
dans ce pays le problème de l'enfant
semble être une brûlante actualité
seuls les églises et un énorme palais de
justice ont droit à des pierres de
taille
est ce le conseil de la misère que l'on
veut juger dans ce palais qui sait
yann chagnaud vous a proposé voyage sans
passeport cette émission a été réalisée
avec le concours de solange péters
montage pierre michel rey sont annick
v10 script nathalie de muret
illustration sonore denise glaser